well he's been cooking since the age of
15. he has two james beard awards he was
even named one of people magazine's most
beautiful people he has a restaurant in
area 15 a restaurant in the virgin hotel
has a new hotel of his own on its way
quite the resume please welcome chef
todd english thank you so nice to be
here thank you i'm so excited to be here
very excited about one of my favorite
times of year the fall season to cook
and obviously my favorite holiday of all
time is thanksgiving coming right up you
know so very excited so this is a dish
that you guys can make at home
it's easy so good it's kind of like a
pum's anna if you had a gratan
you know without further ado let's get
going i'm going to have you join in okay
you're trusting me to help you we'll see
how this goes all right
here are all these things i've got i've
got turnips all right while you just put
a little bit of that in the bottom there
here we go i'm going to show you this
great gadget it's a it's called a
mandolin okay and i love this and it's
you can get this at your fancy kitchen
stores and uh you just slice it very
easy to slice wow we do have a safety
gadget so you don't cut your hand yes
you know and just you get these
beautiful slices
like that but you can also cut it by
hand it works just as well okay but this
is just a little gadget i wanted to show
you how much of this are we doing i'm
just going forward
yeah you're doing great okay now what
we're going to do we're going to like
you and i'm dealing cars in vegas right
all right so let's put some of those in
there okay all right i'm going to follow
behind you all right we'll throw
caramelized onion that's a potato you're
doing great
all right and it doesn't have to be
super fancy you can be as neat as you
want or you know because it all sort of
cooks down together
cheddar cheese and i'm mixing a little
bit of uh italian yeah don't be don't be
shy all right i'm going for that cheese
is my favorite part we're doing this
right all right we've got some
caramelized onions in there oh look at
that and he just continue to do this you
know layer after layer after layer until
it's all the way filled okay like that
and i'm going to show you what this
looks like at the end so we got a little
tv magic going on here exactly so it
bakes about 45 minutes
for 30 minutes i'll bake it um
with a little foil or on top okay well
as you're serving this over to me we
have a lot to talk about because you
have so much going on i tried to kind of
fit your resume into that intro here but
there's no way to fit it all in i
thought you had me on for an hour today
what's that what's going on here we
could talk for an hour this looks
absolutely beautiful as we serve it up
why don't you tell me a little bit about
what you got going on here in los
angeles so i'm very excited we've moved
olives which was at the bellagio for 20
years you know so i've been coming out
here a long time
and we just opened to the virgin hotel
beautiful space cool hotel soup and cool
and fun and i'd say belize one's great
but this is really fun and it's been a
nice nice fun move for us he's kind of
given an update and a refresh look at it
so that's exciting and then we've got
also my restaurant at the beast at area
15. yes which i've been to it's
delicious which is really wacky and fun
yeah and of course
what i'm also very excited about is the
english hotel which is in the arts
district it's like one of the first sort
of only boutique hotels in vegas 74 keys
very much geared we're going to open up
a restaurant the pepper club
which is about asian meats italian meets
all sorts of world food world ideas and
it'll be a nightclub as well so you know
a showroom as well and and the rooms are
beautifully designed um
uh by my friends at
360 design well what did las vegas do to
deserve all of this we're so excited for
you this is the city of entertainment
yes there's always something going on
come to realize that's what this is
about like this city is
i mean if you're gonna do anything like
this this is the best city to do it the
best city to do absolutely i'm so
excited look at that well i'm so excited
to eat this chef todd english thank you
so much we're so excited to have you
continuing to share your work here in
las vegas